sprechen wir mit eckart lohse dem leiter
der parlamentsredaktion der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung hallo herr lohse
herr lohse sprechen wir über das
stichwort einigkeit ist ja vielleicht so
was wie ein überbegriff über diese tage
nach der bundestagswahl und bleiben
gerne bei der union die wir eben auch im
beitrag gesehen haben also einigkeit das
scheint ja da nicht allzu viel zu geben
wie bewerten sie das was gerade in der
union passiert also man hat es ja schon
in den letzten drei jahren sehen können
die einigkeit ging verloren als angela
merkel angekündigt hat dass sie nicht
mehr vorsitzen sein will aber noch drei
jahre kanzlerin und inside dieser
strecke hat die union ist nicht mehr
geschafft im streit zwischen cdu und csu
aber auch innerhalb der cdu eine einige
linie zu finden jetzt eskaliert das ja
geradezu erst mit der im streit über die
kanzlerkandidatur die söder und beide
haben wollten und jetzt nach dem
schlechten wahlergebnis wird es
eigentlich immer dramatischer vor allen
dingen von csu seiten von söder seiten
aus dass er immer wenn vielleicht ein
bisschen beruhigung einkehrt sofort die
wunde wieder aufreißt ich kann es auch
verstehen dass andere parteien sagen da
wären wir skeptisch ob wir mit denen
überhaupt solide verhandlungen führen
können weil wir gar nicht genau wissen
wir hatten da eigentlich prokura bei den
es ist ja so weit gegangen dass gestern
abend volker wissing der generalsekretär
der fdp im heute journal gesagt hat also
diese einladung die die fdp an die union
ausgesprochen hat sich am samstag zu
treffen zu der würde es wohl nicht
kommen weil die union ich zitiere das
mal zeit probleme hätte oder auch in
satow rische probleme wie kann das sein
wie kann an einem samstag etwas
wichtigeres geben für die union als ich
mit der fdp über mögliche sondierung für
die zukunft zu unterhalten ja das kann
überhaupt nicht sein das kann höchstens
sein dass nicht klar ist wer in der
union diese verhandlungen dann führt wer
die nummer eins ist die frage wird ja
auch immer wieder gestellt an den
laschen beansprucht natürlich diese
rolle für sich er war der
kanzlerkandidat er kann das überhaupt
nur machen aber wenn wir die worte
söders von vorgestern uns noch mal in
erinnerung bringen sein hat er ja auch
deutlich gemacht dass die csu dass er da
eine
rolle sich vorstellen kann er war zwar
von einer matrix die rede die die csu
bereits für solche verhandlungen habe
das ist natürlich so etwas öffentlich
vorzutragen bevor der kanzlerkandidat
etwas dazu sagt ist natürlich auch eine
provokation und
nur so kann es zu solchen
schwierigkeiten kommen herr lohse also
braucht man armin laschet jetzt noch für
diese gespräche mit der fdp weil eben
auch dieses verhältnis verhältnis
laschet lindner so eng ist und danach
ihr seht also
eins ist ja klar jetzt braucht man ihn
auf jeden fall wenn die union jetzt ist
die cdu dann die csu zweifel daran
aufkommen lässt wer da der
kanzlerkandidat war wer der vorsitzende
ist und wer solche gespräche ganz gleich
wohin sie führen führt ich glaube dann
muss sie gar nicht mehr sich um
gesprächspartner bemühen es muss klar
sein dass das ohne streit dass man ohne
streit zumindest diese ersten
sondierungen führt das scheint ja schon
schwierig zu sein was dann daraus wird
das ist höchst ungewiss übrigens hört
man das ja auch in der cdu schon dass
das die hoffnung dass ist zu einer
jamaika koalition kommt nicht gerade
wachsen im moment aber wenn jetzt eine
demontage jetzt die ja gegen dessen
willen stattfände käme also dann wäre
der streit perfekt und dann würde ich
glaube ich jede partei gesagt mit denen
lieber nicht verhandeln würde ich
verstehen guck mal von der union weg und
schauen mal zu den beiden neuen man
denkt ja fast schon lieblingspartnern
grünen und fdp wie groß ist denn die
einigkeit tatsächlich in den letzten
wochen monaten vielleicht auch jahren
geworden nach diesem eklat 2017 als
christian lindner sicher aus den
sondierungsgesprächen aus den gesprächen
zu einer neuen koalition zurückgezogen
hat man habe immer gesprächskontakt
gehalten man hat natürlich
in beiden parteien gewusst sie sehen ja
auch die zahlen dass die möglichkeit
eines dreierbündnisses nach der wahl
jetzt
vorhanden ist das war klar ist
zwischenzeitlich mal nach option
schwarz-grün aus aber man kann sich ja
darauf vorbereiten dreierbündnis ist
möglich daher immer kontakte gehalten
werden sie haben es ja eben
in der sendung auch schon aufgearbeitet
es gibt natürlich einige inhaltliche
differenzen einige schnittstellen gerade
die rechtspolitik die rechtsstaats
politik da ist manches wo man
zusammenkommen kann bildungspolitik aber
es gibt natürlich bei steuer- und
sozialpolitik
da ist es fraglich es gab in der
asylpolitik große unterschiede aber
vergessen wenn ich zwei jahre nach dem
großen
flüchtlingsstreit 215 haben
fdp und grüne 217 miteinander verhandelt
und gescheitert ist das ganze nicht
daran dass die beiden sich zerlegt haben
sondern dass lindner angst hatte dass
die damals einige cdu und der angela
merkel sich zu sehr auf die grünen ein
lässt es war aber nicht das hauptproblem
dass fdp und grünen nicht zusammen
kommen also da teile ich die
einschätzung von ihrem gesprächspartner
gerhart baum eben dass wir schon
hinkriegen aber doch immer die gleiche
wollte ich eben auch gerd baum gestellt
haben die sich dann doch auch an ihre
ausführungen doch anlehnt nämlich die
frage wer sagt uns denn dass christian
gentner nicht diesmal wieder das gleiche
gespür und gefühle hat somalia spd und
grüne sicher näher sind als cdu und
grüne damals 2017 union und grüne 2017
der riesen unterschied ist zwischen
lindner und merkel bestand ein
ausgesprochen spannungsreiches
verhältnis vor allen dingen merkel hatte
einen sehr negativen blick auf lindner
das wusste er
das verhältnis war angespannt und
lindner hatte angst dass die mächtige
cdu chefin und kanzlerin ihn als 5 670
rad am wagen behandelt das ist jetzt
ganz anders erstens lindner laschet
haben ein gutes verhältnis nicht zuletzt
durch das regieren in
nordrhein-westfalen in einer
schwarz-gelben regierung zweitens wenn
es überhaupt weitere schritte geben
sollte über sondierungen hinaus laschet
ist natürlich geschwächt das heißt die
sorge lindners von damals die bügeln uns
unter die ist natürlich geringer aber
dann doch da und die letzte frage wie
ist steht sondern um die spd mit den
beiden also wie eng ist das verhältnis
von olaf scholz zu christian lindner
beispielsweise in diesem sinne nicht so
eng wie zwischen laschet und lindner
aber wir kennen alle christian lindner
und das weiss man übrigens in der cdu
auch ganz genau mit einer ist dann
pragmatiker weiß dass es nicht sehr gut
kenne und wahrscheinlich bedrohlich für
ihn würde wenn er noch also etwas machte
wie vor vier jahren plötzlich abspringen
aus verhandlungen christian lindner ist
clever genug dann auch ein zusammengehen
mit der spd als großes projekt zu
verkaufen also das traue ich ihm
durchaus zu auch wenn sein verhältnisse
scholz nicht so eng ist zu löschen da
ist es wieder dieses wort projekt was
gerhard baum schon geprägt hat eckart
lohse vielen dank ihr leiter der
parlamentsredaktion der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung vielen dank für die
hintergründe